steve built an eddie van halen drill and
5150 replica guitar over the weekend
like he's super
drill he rebuilt yeah what is that all
about steve i got a bunch of friends
that are all like we're all hardcore
eddie van halen replica builders and i
was working with a buddy of mine on uh
this 5150 replica over the weekend
when you say you built it what do you
mean by actually building it what do you
what did you do so you get like the body
is cut out of wood and the neck is cut
out of wood and the frets are in it and
everything so then from there i built
like
fake wood grain i matched eddie's wood
grain that he had on the original 5150
and then from there i spray paint it i
paint on fake cigarette burns and
do all the chips in it and all that but
the process of really building this and
getting like every
like every dent in this i sat with an
exacto knife and perfectly carved
like every chip out of the paint and how
do you know
that yeah how do you how do you know how
to do that i mean do you have pictures
of eddie's guitar to work from is that
what you're looking at
yeah like furiously looking at like
every little picture going through getty
images and just zooming in on every
little piece and like
finding out about the history like eddie
actually took a razor blade to the neck
of this
and took all the finish off so there's
chunks of the neck that have finish
chunks of it that don't i'm curious why
would eddie take the finish off of
certain places is that to get a certain
sound
yeah he liked the feel of like a raw
wood neck and unfinished neck so
the guys at kramer that built this
guitar for eddie in 1982 they gave it to
him finished
so he just took a razor blade and
started chopping and you know you could
see the parts where he just kind of got
bored of or he's missed a few chunks of
it and the rest has all this
just natural dirt from his fingers in it
you built the exact power drill that
eddie van halen used when
he used to play the guitar with a power
drill but this is the exact power drill
it's a makita 6012 it's from the late
80s it was one of the first uh cordless
power drills
so then you plug it in at the beginning
of the song pound cake eddie goes like
[Music]
this
oh my gosh
[Music]
look at you wailing away on that thing
how do you learn to play with a power
drill how do you do that do you watch
him on video or something
in the music video to pound cake you see
him doing the
the thing right there and it just you
know the motor goes in through
uh through the pickup
look at you yeah i had to my whole
weekend was eddie van halen it was this
guitar this drill and just
listening to his music non-stop i
thought you had a girlfriend
i do where is that girlfriend